how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
calendar where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and today we have a
truly awesome plot league for venema 2
now there's been a lot of changes that
happen to venom 2 recently we got an
official title for the film a very tiny
teaser for the film and the release date
has unfortunately been pushed back but
luckily for us we actually do have quite
a bit of information about the film many
different leaks including photos videos
and over the past couple of days I've
gotten a lot of questions about a
certain venom to plot leak that connects
venom 2 with Morbius and Spider Man and
I have to say this is by far the best
plot leak that I've heard so far and if
it ends up being legitimate venom 2 is
going to be a fantastic movie so let's
dive into it and if you're new be sure
to subscribe with notifications turned
on so you can stay up to date on
everything related to Marvel and venom 2
and the 550,000 winner has been chosen
you can check out a video I did on it a
couple of days ago and we're starting
weekly giveaways in May so if you did
not catch the official title reveal for
venom 2 it is venom
let there be carnage people seem to have
mixed feelings about this title but it
does suit the movie well a lot of people
would have rather it have been called
maximum carnage like the comic series
was but keep in mind it's not the exact
same storyline so they're not gonna call
it the same thing but I bet you if Kevin
Feige was a hundred percent in charge of
choosing the title he would have called
it maximum carnage but today's plot
leaked a lot of people have been asking
me about and it is truly great now if
you are trying to avoid any and all
spoilers for venom 2 and Morbius I
suggest you click away now if you are
with me this leak is a compliation of
different leaks from multiple sources
including comicbook.com
reddit and definition co uk i've done
plenty of videos on some of these leaks
in the past but we're tying them all
together in this video and they make a
lot of sense
now although this isn't titled maximum
carnage and although it's not going to
be the exact same story as maximum
carnage it is going to have a lot of
similarities for example the very
beginning of the movie is reportedly
going to start off just as the beginning
of maximum carnage started off but with
a little twist
according to a report from insider
Daniel RPK serial killer Cletus Kasady
will be in prison
in the facility awaiting execution for
his crimes this facility is the very
familiar asylum for the criminally
insane
the Ravencroft Institute this was teased
in the post-credits scene of venom one
now the Ravencroft Institute in the
comics is in New York but they have
moved that from New York to California
for venom two now here's where things
get very very interesting and tie into
Morbius and possibly the sinister six
according to a Morbius plot leaked in
the film is rumored that Morbius is
going to go to jail and it's there where
he comes face to face with the vulture
and scorpion in prison
Morbius vulture and scorpion all meet up
Morbius ends up causing a prison riot in
order to escape and during this vulture
and scorpion escape as well at some
point vulture would then tell Morbius
that he's forming a team and asked if he
wants to get involved now this is most
likely the scene that they showed us in
the Morbius trailer where vulture is
talking to Morbius vulture is wearing a
prison uniform and Morbius as walking
down the alleyway and vulture definitely
knows who he is so it is safe to assume
that vulture and Morbius definitely have
met before and considering the fact that
vulture is still wearing his prison
uniform it is likely that this leak is
accurate that they met each other in
prison and then both escaped but here's
the kicker and the tie in this league
says that when Morbius causes the prison
riot and vulture Morbius and scorpion
escape cletus kasady also escapes that's
right according to this leak cletus
kasady is going to be in the same prison
as vulture scorpion and Morbius now this
is awesome news but doesn't come as that
big of a surprise because we know that
all of these movies venom venom to
Morbius and upcoming spider-verse films
are going to link together because Sony
does have their own spider-verse so the
fact that they're crossing over is
definitely awesome
but is expected now shriek has been
confirmed for the movie as well and it
has been confirmed that she is going to
be played by Naomi Harris and just like
in maximum carnage shriek is in the
prison with Cletus Kasady and manages to
escape with him and follows him now
here's where things get very interesting
and really crazy Cletus is going to
escape from the prison and Eddie Brock
is going to hunt him down
but during this time Cletus Kasady
somehow gets infected with
carnage symbiote which is a spawn of
venom we then learn that riot is still
alive and carnage and riot end up
connecting with each other and they help
infect shriek now this is going to be a
little bit different from the comics
because in the comics shriek doesn't
actually wear a symbiote
she actually has mutant abilities and is
able to manipulate sound now in maximum
carnage she breaks out of the prison
with Cletus Kasady and then she follows
carnage on a killing spree along their
path of their killing spree carnage and
shrink end up gaining a lot of followers
who would like to kill as well and they
all end up looking at carnage and shriek
as their mother and father
well that appears to be happening in
venom let there be carnage as well the
League goes on to say that Cassidy's
insanity begins to infect the carnage
symbiote and it slowly becomes just as
twisted as he is riot ends up alerting
the other symbiotes on his home planet
that there are people on earth to feed
upon they arrive on earth but due to
carnage now being corrupted it becomes
cannibalistic and he begins to attack
the other symbiotes and feed upon them
this is similar to how riot absorbed
venom in the first film and it's
apparently what we will see when the
symbiote reached earth and venom to
carnage will absorb them all and become
stronger because of it and we will get
the giant carnage from the comics
however carnage doesn't absorb riot or
shriek and instead he plays it cool and
pretends to be their ally waiting until
the right moment to absorb them he
becomes their leader and together they
all team up against venom now according
to this new leak this is apparently
where venom slash Eddie Brock is going
to reach out to spider-man slash Peter
Parker now if we think about who Eddie
Brock is he's a reporter and a pretty
good reporter at that he probably is
kept up with the events of spider-man
and since Mysterio revealed spider-man
to actually be Peter Parker and
spider-man far from home Eddie Brock
knows that spider-man is Peter Parker
Eddie Brock with his reporter skills is
probably somewhat of a good detective as
well so if he wanted to find spider-man
he probably could and according to this
leak that's what he's going to do and
that's all this leaks says but we did
have another leak a couple of months ago
that said that spider-man was going to
be in the end of venom 2 and the final
battle venom is about to kill Cletus
Kasady not carnage but Cletus Kasady but
spider-man
stops him and this is apparently where
venom is going to turn on spider-man and
this will start their long lasting feud
and apparently could somehow in the
future set up a spider-man vs. venom
film but that's a long shot
however spider-man appearing in venom is
not a long shot and is actually pretty
probable about a week ago Tom Hardy
posted a picture to his Instagram of
venom eating spider-man he basically bit
him in half but he deleted the photo
about a minute after it was out now this
isn't uncommon for Tom Hardy to do
especially when it comes to venom - he's
actually posted and deleted photos
pretty much instantly a few times when
it comes to venom - however just a few
days ago when we got the venom to
official title and teaser he did it
again so he posted and deleted the photo
twice and of course we all think it
means something and then you have to
consider the fact that Sony wanted Tom
Hollands spider-man to appear in the
first venom film however Marvel said no
they didn't want people to confuse the
Marvel Cinematic Universe with the
spider verse that Sony has however it
looks like spider-man just spider-man
and all of the spider-man characters in
the MCU are going to bleed over into
Sony spider verse and to think about Tom
Hardy posting and then deleting photos
is that they've actually all meant
something in the past Tom Hardy once
posted a photo of a very crucial
location and teased what to expect in
the film in the photo you could see a
crest that said Saint Estes orphans
which also read home for unwanted
children in the comics Saint Estes home
for boys as the orphanage where the
serial killer Cletus Kasady
grew up and seemingly got the taste for
murder and the comics he would go on to
push a girl who rejected him in front of
a bus and would eventually burn down the
orphanage and that's really what this
photo looks like it looks like the
orphanage is rundown and in ruins and
according to this leak that is
apparently what Eddie Brock is going to
be investigating in the film after Brock
does some serious investigation work he
will uncovered that 12 deaths were
caused by Cletus Kasady himself and it's
believed that in the post-credits seam
of the first venom film where Eddie
Brock is talking to Cletus Kasady in the
prison Eddie Brock learned some
information that leads him to the
orphanage and after exposing his victims
Cassidy will hunt him down in order to
stop the news getting out if
gonna be carnage
so this is apparently why Cletus Kasady
is going to want to hunt down and kill
Eddie Brock in venom let there be
carnage so of course not only are we
going to be seeing venom versus carnage
but we're actually really going to be
getting a Cletus Kasady versus Eddie
Brock as well
now unfortunately as I mentioned in the
beginning if you didn't know the film
has been pushed back instead of coming
out on October 2nd of 2020 it is now
coming out on June 25th of 2021 now
what's really interesting is that
Morbius was originally scheduled to be
released on July 31st of 2020 however
this movie got pushed back as well and
is now coming out on March 19th of 2021
this keeps it ahead of venom so if this
leak is true and Morbius vulture and
scorpion are the ones that help Cletus
Kasady break out of prison this all
still lines up which means that it could
very well be true and would be the
perfect way to tie the movies together
and it also means that the sinister six
is coming but let me know what you think
about this plot leak if this is how the
movie is going to go would you enjoy it
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to give
the video a like and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on everything that
is happening with venom 2 and of course
all things Marvel for live updates on
news you can follow me on Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof